[Music]
i'm deborah cullen director and chief
curator of the Wallach art gallery at
Columbia University and this is
relational undercurrents contemporary
art of the Caribbean archipelago this is
an exhibition that originated at the
Museum of Latin American art in Long
Beach it's part of the Getty Pacific
Standard time initiative it was curated
by a graduate of the art history
department here at Columbia University
and we thought it was the perfect
exhibition to travel to New York New
York being one of the largest Caribbean
cities in the world the idea was to
bring about make visible connections
that were not necessarily clear because
even the the Caribbean has typically
seen as an space of heterogeneity and
fragmentation and what I wanted to point
out were points of common and community
even though from people who's so
different languages and who didn't know
of each other's work the four themes of
the show are perpetual horizons works
that emphasize the horizon and the the
insular perspective conceptual mappings
works that think about map and place in
ways that really reject the colonial
legacy of mapping the region and build
forge their own connections we have a
section called landscape ecology z--
which focuses on landscape and
environment and in which artists are
kind of meditate on ways of thinking
about nature that call attention to
natural disasters but also to kind of
contract the tourist view of the
Caribbean as one and less white sanded
beach this work is a way to think about
carried the Caribbean as a monolith and
the way that people speak about the
Caribbean is a monolith
so in a way what I did with this is I
combined five different Caribbean
islands Trinidad Barbados Martinique
Jamaica and Haiti to come up with this
island and it's also a way to think
about people having to rebuild their
lives after things after their lives
have been destroyed the title of the
work is thirst - and the data that is
shown on the work is showing you the
cost of 100 gallons of clean water
supply to 16 cities throughout the world
this baby actually represents banyan
trees that although they're not native
to the caribbean they're in basically
every you know major park in the
Caribbean and when I think of Cuba which
is where I'm from
I'm always think of the parks with the
banyan trees so these paintings were
actually made on site and I made them on
purpose from different perspectives
right he said to me they represented a
really interesting metaphor for
immigration community and how really we
migrate over time right it's great to be
in my hometown in New York and as a New
Year Rican showing my work at home is
wonderful to talk about and explore the
themes of mapmaking of cultures in the
Caribbean and as a Jamaican Puerto Rican
I really enjoy talking about how all of
these closures interlink and what that
looks like in the tensions of that and
the beauty of that just like it is in
New York City it's really great to have
a venue and an institution here I can
bring like my nephew here like it's not
you know all the way downtown or it's
not all the way in Brooklyn you know and
it's really great to sort of have an
arts venue an additional arts venue
because there's a studium Museum there's
a Schaumburg but you know somewhere else
to go to sort of take in and experience
Caribbean identity
and within the space of you know America
in the world I love the whole concept of
a Caribbean I saw how all because we're
in the same ocean same you know madakari
Bay with the Atlantic and it's
interesting because of the colonial past
we have it's all fragmented but I think
we all have the same background roots we
share a lot of histories in common
this is a perfect exhibition to bring to
New York City not only to our campus but
the broader community relational
undercurrents will also be shared with
our neighbors Sugar Hill Museum of
children's art in storytelling it's
really important for the Wallach to
continue always in collaboration with
not only the campus but our neighboring
institutions